we've got a voicemail for you today a
couple weeks ago a cunning linguist
called in and said I was mispronouncing
the word new saying it should be
pronounced new he called back in after I
pointed out that both pronunciations are
acceptable and now it is abundantly
clear that the British accent this
person is calling in with his also fake
take a listen to this hello David this
is the cunning linguist I called last
week and told you about your liquid new
pronunciation of the word new I wanted
to call you back and tell you that I
stand corrected
I've gone online and looked it up in the
truth is you all right the pronunciation
of the word new may also be filled with
a big glorious liquid you the way you
said you yeah so anyway excellent job
and I continue to thank you and your
vagin friend Pat you're a wonderful
remarkable shoe dude a thank you
completely different British accent than
last time somebody from a clearly a
completely confused region of the United
Kingdom we've got a great bonus show for
you today
and it relates to yet another nor'easter
that we are suffering from today david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show don't miss
today's bonus show it's a good one